you
miss cherry I'm on elite chess org and
I'm going to play 1510 game arcade God
is the opponent
okay caro-kann land
the top-level see the advanced variation
Norway
magnus carlsen account all right let's
take there isn't anything better
I've played this before in rapid time
controls
let's go with each six
preparing this in meeting night g3 with
Bishop to h7
I believe at least interferes with this
age pone race and a valuable tempo
against the bishop not a hundred percent
on that
okay
side the chain I'm not doing
that something is wrong
so phase 1 okay so this is a very solid
approach
neither of us has any weaknesses it's a
peace play position
okay let's go here
secure my bishop
and we'll see
do next so I'm thinking immediately
challenge that night
we have to be a little bit careful
the knight f6 if take Queen takes the
move that concerns me a little bit is
going to be 3a
during Bishop takes Bishop here take
take Queen b3 Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes pawn I could in that position play
Queen takes Bishop yeah okay I'd get two
minor pieces so let me consider one
other variation Bishop takes Bishop
Queen takes and then Queen b3 I think
I've actually had something like this
maybe even blitz if Queen b3 in that
position I could swing over to b5 and I
know it's not ideal to take away from
the center if Queen takes Queen but I
think my grip over the light squares
with the position absent of light
squared Bishop s' is is quite all right
and if a for I have B for an important
reply because I would not want to see
the a file open up there's something
else I'm missing because this will set
off a chain reaction of minor piece
exchanges I don't believe I'm missing
anything so let's let's go for it
hey I'm not a hundred percent if I I
think past rapid time control games I've
played for the channel were fifteen five
so this one's slightly longer
what did her Weitzman replies okay I
definitely have to take with the Queen
take with the pawn here I'd have triple
isolated pawns that's something's a
little off with that
okay in general I'm not a fan of helping
to develop my opponents peace with a
capture here but
I go here um no no no I could still just
do that yeah this this pressure is no
longer an issue also those lines so I
guess I could
97 maybe even bish maybe even queen g6
[Music]
I'm gonna say let's let's take the fish
up
that way at least I don't have to worry
about the Queen striking at b7 okay
hmm I'm a I'm actually considering
something else here besides Knight to d7
I'm anticipating the night will arrive
on e5 as it stands right now I only have
one spot for my bishop but I may want to
go back home and play Bishop to d6 maybe
Queen c7 and Knight to d7 all of these
moves are fixated on e5 challenging any
white piece that may arrive there it
certainly comes off as slow but I don't
think in the end I'm about far behind in
development and I have control over that
any pawn breaks that may be present d5
is the only one I'm looking at I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say
go for this idea yeah Queen back home
mission accomplished
well done Yuri captured on f6 now go
home
so I wonder what White's reaction will
be after Bishop to d6 let's
find out
to keep the tension or not made
right in Oh ooh did not expect queenside
castles okay
takes takes
inside this is a very simplified
position soon just playing with one
minor piece so it takes takes Queen a
five my queen is getting quite the
workout
a jab at eight - King here and then 97
my queen a night fight for this and I'm
prepared for Queen side castles one
minor piece on board I think I'm alright
with that my opponent has a little bit
more space with the pawn but is this an
advantage with just one minor piece I
don't think so I'm going to shoot the
exchange
you
f6d eight
five
considering something else really
really that would be the
immediate move should I should I should
I in fact play this
here there's 95 allowing this capture
just to be a little bit annoying you
know I can't so we I can't easily play
97 then I'd have to go and castled yeah
the other really isn't
what's what's the hurry with this
okay one of the things I have to watch
out for is that if my reversal is rook
is unprotected for too long this g4 g5
idea can hurt me
so playing here here three moves Queen a
five here 97g four castles just in the
nick of time and that move I can take
rooks are connected at that stage so if
I start with this G four Queen here
maybe white ignores the threat then and
plays g5 hmm I don't know maybe the move
order really isn't mattering so much
yeah let's just go with Knight to d7
maybe just a coin flip at the end of the
day
yeah okay so now maybe maybe no actually
now that King b1 is in there cleaning a
5 maybe is not best maybe better to make
this this move Queen c7 seems a bit
cozier I know there's more mobility one
the ones posted on 85 but I think
fighting for the e5 square from this
post hmm yeah here's the thing I want to
not only fight for e5 but d6 I'm
with this move I guess anticipating that
if there's ever a pawn recapturing on e5
and this may be a focal point then or it
certainly would be a focal point
intersection square d6 oh my queen
controls d6 on a5 she would not so these
the more important squares I feel at
least to focus on okay
at the d5 huh poof
well I may have to change plans here I
was intending on queenside councils
queenside castles d5 and this is a bit
annoying having my king queen on the
same file night here stops this but
allows the night to improve but I could
get this move in and I wonder
maybe it is
play Knight up six here let me see if I
got going into the queenside castle d5 I
don't I don't have to uh I don't have to
take with the C pawn so let's say
castles d5 I could take and after take
six and there is d6 then
hmm also Queen f5 move with check in
some lines I'm going to say let's try
and prevent d5 I'm giving this up okay
you dive right in alright it seems just
far too scary to go kingside this
half-opened file blink fast I write well
this I think is uh is necessary
[Music]
should I be trying to challenge this
night hmm I'm just gonna make sure I
don't know just in case any anything
exciting happens with the C file opening
up I want to get my queen and king off
of the same file okay just some nice
centralization here by team white um I
was thinking this but what about now
that the rook isn't done the H file
suppose I consider this advance I'm
giving up this square to the Queen that
could be a bit irritating yeah and I
like that so maybe I just have to stay
with this quark rip and
[Music]
play here and then challenge the night
let's give this a go
you
down on time
big surprise all right night let's see
what we're gonna do here to trade or not
nope
all right
okay should I try and maybe provoke some
weaknesses let's see let's just go here
for a second great reasoning right try
that in my own game he went there for a
second okay so the king is a little bit
a little more area over here near the
King WA alright let's come back mission
accomplished my knight is out of play
now long term maybe I have in my back
pocket the potential for perpetual
checks if the Queen's are maintained
white seems to you know finding
justification for this move there's now
a nice forward Square for the King how
exactly do I make progress
it's poking around
a little bit suppose I go here
threatening the pawn after this maybe I
come back my night is getting a workout
taking a page out of the Queen's book
here okay let me I don't know what more
could really do here you know this stuff
I have to also be aware of this
possibility although I wouldn't mind
this stuff the night angling in I will
give up a ruck for a night in a pond and
have a nice square for my night
me I don't know I'm it's tough to come
up with a plan here being perfectly
honest don't know you're gonna continue
to to duck this night exchange yeah I
mean where are my I don't want to make
moves that hurt my position so
maybe maybe queen here I don't know
let's let's play play ball right I don't
know this is the play ball move I don't
want to just continually go back and
forth but I don't know really what kind
of a progress I can make here like now
if I go here what is my knight even
doing
I don't know let's
try this okay where's the Queen down
we back up she better over here to watch
this Oh getting the f-pawn rolling okay
well hmm
this weakens this square the thinking
about a committal move this move will be
bad and I can't circle into this
weakness I'm supposed to this break can
I can i maybe try for that I wonder
hmm tough tough tough here throws a
punch at the pond actually oh here
they'll give me a shove
take take double isolated pawns but then
there's something here my night remains
clumsy where is a good square for my
night here with this idea tough it's
tough to say it really is also the nice
ready to come in and after take they're
going to take like that I have to do
this and maybe shoot for this pawn break
hmm okay this is committal but I'm going
to try it this idea to uh jump in and
take like that is scaring me so no no
tough to say if this is really a good
idea
okay the King backs up here here and
then go for this rooks unprotected after
this move but I don't see exactly how
it's taken advantage of
let's do it I could play this but here
and then I'm ready to take away mmm I
missing some move with a no I'm not
quite all right I guess I guess we go
here
yeah it's a tough it's a tough one here
I don't know
inch up a little bit
oh hey
it's a big decision I go here I guess my
Queens gonna get trapped all right so I
gotta go here and what's the plan now
this now that I'm in a pin you're just
gonna form a a super battery
yikes fish okay
ah I just have to sit I don't know I
better start playing faster I don't know
I'm just gonna have to go completely
passive here what else am I gonna do
this and then here is that the plan am I
forced to do this just to stop this here
in here putting every single white piece
on the e6
yeah I guess okay normally don't like to
budge with my cork grip but I kind of
felt compelled to do these moves okay
so now what I guess we just over protect
e6 hope for the best
there's a check on g3 I can never take
care for as long as these three animals
stick around yeah okay
I see I see what's going on and it's
it's not good news for me in every
however I look at it justification right
I thought that this is a weakness and
look at the Knights now gonna be in keto
fiend keto tonight the most dangerous
maneuver okay
if anything I could do here I'm just
tied up in a giant huh this is to this
night is hitting so hard I mean do I
have to play this like look at all the
concessions I have to make I guess I
have to play this move just to keep and
try and keep the knight out of here
okay you could take you're gonna take
down to three more time than what we
started with okay
yeah I thought you might do that oh so
after this the Queen could be a slippery
piece sneak in here I got to maintain
stuff clean here and then the
it comes in like this clean here night
here bring in the pain clean here can I
take care first what's the plan team
white
okay still can't do anything here
where's the night going where is he
going where is he going step up with the
King and I guess
clean here clean here I still have
enough defense on this Square this is
barely barely barely held together three
bare Lee's okay here take take take take
I need two one two three four one two
three four right I need to stick around
here this take take yeah I'm losing out
okay took a little bit I have to play
the waiting game and I guess it's I also
probably is probably going to be this
stuff and then clean slipping in here is
that the winning play uncle uncle uncle
there's maybe even this push coming oh
that's the that's going to be the nail
in the coffin I think
[Music]
what can I do
the this idea here is happening I don't
know let's just go here and see what the
the plan is okay first a ciao show me
the way I am toast yes of course and I
must take like this and then my king is
gonna be in a pickle the knight can take
how okay
could throw in the towel now
while more moves out
I wonder
that move played
and there's something better
this and try and close it up maybe the
first big thing all right
considering maybe this
this
and I know what a poor night yeah okay
so most precise probably yeah
I'll just I guess I'll still just play a
couple moves just to see the the very
best moves I think this is best
what white did night quality yeah I'd
rather be white here for sure
Wow rook to d4 killer
foof boom-boom-boom getting squeezed
many times over okay
I was ready to go here
how long it would take white to take my
rook if I took on that five in a blink
probably in a blink opponent is offering
a drop tell you what
I'll accept that drop that was
surprising because I feel that this is
it a completely winning position for
white so a mysterious and draw offer
from arcade God Norway
all right let's have a look the very
first thing I want to do
[Music]
is get a computer evaluation before I go
any further and we'll see what the tally
is here inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders for each it started off very
quiet
let's see
guess I could flick this on right now
what's the name of this I'm forgetting
h6 yes finished a variation okay okay
very simplified Queen to d8 yeah
happy about that one move that's about
it though the Queen the DA okay I found
a best move going home okay that's about
it though
queenside castles yeah see if King sight
castles I think I'll find it much easier
to well I first of all could safely go
Kings side and then I could look forward
to a c5 break
and we once more visit equal territory
okay so I know what queenside
and I was probably spending too much
time on which of these two moons to go
with I guess it doesn't really matter
the order so 97 at the end of the day if
I go here can be 197 yeah okay doesn't
really matter so next time I can maybe
save save a minute clean 85 Queen f6
mm-hmm did not consider of Queen f6 here
c4 we did a lot of night dancing and
white is and then it's definitely the
right idea here to avoid the night
exchange as we saw by inducting these
exchanges in the end right in that final
position where I'm completely losing the
difference of the Knights is just jumps
right off the board so avoid the knight
exchange and second ranked night versus
third ranked night white knight is in
the sweet spot and this guy is not so b3
just poking for you know trying to
create some weaknesses but I don't know
where is it completely losing how do we
get to this point so let me actually
take a peek at what it has to say
accuracies for mistakes no blunders and
my opponent had a triple zero game okay
let's see Queen d6 f3 I don't know what
can you do
my opponent is playing perfect moves so
I don't have a constructive plan here
mmm
a5 it's suggesting
a 5mn
I don't know I'm I'm inferior no matter
what I do here and the night quality in
this space even I was saying a little
bit earlier the space advantage that
white has I don't think will be an
advantage because we're only playing
with one minor piece but white is
demonstrating that yeah there it is an
advantage still and I'm gonna find a way
to make your night always look clumsy
so yeah I don't know I'm a bit baffled
all around really like why why why offer
a draw you know when you're completely
winning I'm Queen e1
and then g5 yeah I'm just lashing out
here have five I feel a sit Wayne
approach I don't know something's white
could slowly improve and I'm just stuck
completely passive so in this final
position where are we at we're staring
at a plus five plus eight and then this
was the point I was offered to draw okay
well I don't know what more to really
say about this one white played a really
good game and there was a good good
demonstration of how to still show an
advantage with the space white hat even
though we just had one minor piece of
piece one one night apiece
I don't know a mysterious end to this
one with the draw offer out of a carro
con
for that fee and cutout night okay
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you maybe took
something away from this one and that's
all for now take care bye
you